[Musique]
on fait quoi dans une bibliothèque ou
dans une médiathèque
et exactement et dans une marque toc
des tableaux exactement les oeuvres donc
vous êtes ici dans une heure de teck à
côté par exemple il y a un musée le
musée lui dire et il y a une différence
entre une architecte et un musée c'est
que le musée on emprunte pas
[Musique]
le choix de d'année donc les oeuvres or
les murs et de choisir comme messager
des compteurs l'idée c'est que les
compteurs soient également partie
prenantes acteurs même du projet et
c'est eux qui ont choisi dans les
collections de l'artothèque les oeuvres
qu'ils souhaitaient amener dans les
écoles
un enfant les femmes
[Musique]
la route est longue les gars
allez vas-y
bien toi
[Musique]
continue
dans l'océan
[Musique]
atiala avait plusieurs clans le clan la
pop patate le clan maïdori le clan la
Potomac le clan coco de l'eau
[Musique]
la sculpture c'est boule en moustique
quel est votre super pouvoir
[Musique]
je peux je suis l'homme aussi et je peux
traverser les murs je peux
je peux remonter le temps je peux
exaucer des vœux ce que tu demandes je
peux faire disparaître les maladies avec
un claquement de doigts est-ce que la
sculpture c'est
l'homme en train de faire quelque chose
ou bien
juste un support pour coller vos
demandes
[Musique]
comment tu fais
on a on a fini pour nos prières
et maintenant qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire
le
bonhomme le bonhomme est-ce que vous
est-ce que avec tout ce qu'on a dit là
ça vous donne des idées pour faire le
bonhomme
partager les richesses vivre de l'amour
stop au maladies au virus la vue doit
être
danse une pierre
regarde
la planète
prendre soin de la planète prendre soin
de la planète
prends soin de la planète
[Musique]
et donc si tout le monde doit parler
tout le monde doit dire quelque chose on
a tous quelque chose à dire parce qu'on
a tous une émotion qui va surgir par
rapport à une œuvre donc du coup moi
j'ai écrit sur les chemins de l'art sur
le chemin de l'art nous nous sommes
promenés et c'est vous que je vous
imaginez en train de vous promener
écoutez ce que je vous dis sur le chemin
de l'art nous nous sommes promenés dans
les pas des artistes
nous nous sommes baladés
et donc c'est à ça que je vous invite
moi je vous invite à une balade sur les
pas de ces artistes qui nous ont laissé
ses œuvres là
qu'est-ce que ça va vous inspirer ça
c'était quel mot le premier mot qui
était sorti un jour
c'était quelle horreur
qu'est-ce qu'il a inspiré pourquoi il a
fait cette photo et qu'est-ce qu'il a
voulu montrer et qu'est-ce que peut-être
il veut passer comme message et
qu'est-ce que vous ça peut vous inspirer
comme message à faire passer au travers
ce message
aux personnes qui ont fait ça exactement
et à travers tout le monde parce que là
tout le monde va en parler
que ça va faire des bobos à des animaux
dans la merde allez on garde tout dans
sa tête et on va le noter
[Musique]
sur le chemin de c'est bien les
interrogations alors là on est à ça sur
le chemin de l'art nous sommes promenés
[Musique]
la sculpture en pierre
serait-elle un petit village
[Musique]
sur le chemin de l'art de nous sommes
promenés sur le chemin de la nous sommes
promenés et j'ai joué
dans la neige j'ai fait l'ange la neige
on est seul maître en fait on crée ce
qu'on veut donc là c'est à vous de
laisser aller ce qui vous inspire quand
vous voyez ça quoi
un mot une émotion
[Musique]
ce qui était intéressant c'était de voir
que finalement les élèves entraient dans
les œuvres
et puis arrivé petit à petit à
s'approprier les oeuvres non pas à
travers une seule discipline mais à se
rendre compte qu'on pouvait aller dans
plein d'autres univers
on a voulu
remettre en place la posture que l'on a
lorsqu'on écoute donc il y a eu un parti
pris d'être assis au sol et finalement
d'écouter ce que les oeuvres ont à nous
dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'on touche ça je pense que ça
ça permet de changer un petit peu le
regard sur le monde qui nous entoure
[Musique]